yesterday there was the ceremony for the
closing of the International Year of
chemistry the ceremony was in Brussels I
really wanted to be there but
unfortunately I had to be in London and
I missed a really exciting piece of news
the new names for elements 114 and 116
they haven't actually officially
approved the names yet but they've said
this is the names that we're considering
elements 114 116 were discovered through
a collaboration between the lab in
Russia and a lab in America so one name
is Russian and the other name is
American the name for element 114 is
Fleur ovum with the symbol F L big f
little L the other name 116 suggested is
livermorium with a symbol L V so let me
try and explain to you why they've
chosen those names and my feelings about
them first of all I'm really delighted
that the two names have signaled
collaboration between Russia and the
United States this is a really good
symbol of peace between the two
countries
now the first element that 114 is named
after the scientist who founded the lab
in Dubna where the elements were
actually synthesized and his name if you
look at it in English letters is fleur
off his full name is gilded nikolaivich
flew off the difficulty that I see with
his name is that the English letter that
looks like E is in Russian in his name
pronounced like yo like the beginning of
yogurt
the difficulty therefore is that the way
the Russians would pronounce this name
and
name of the scientists that we are
honoring will not be properly reflected
by the way that people will pronounce it
because they'll pronounce it fluro viim
or something like that where the e is
pronounced like an English e the obvious
way to pronounce it is Floridian but the
way you should say it's flor rove IAM
flerovium floor oven in arabian that's
just a perhaps you can argue some of the
other names are not pronounced in the
correct way so perhaps it doesn't matter
and the other one livermorium is named
after the Lawrence Livermore Lab which
created some of the elements that were
used as the targets for the big
experiment in the synthesis that was
named after Lawrence Ernest Lawrence who
was the inventor of the cyclotron you
can hear about that on our video about
Laurentian the lab is called Lawrence
Livermore and it was founded in 1952 to
make atomic bombs at the height of the
Cold War so if you like it was a really
pretty anti-communist anti-russian
institution so the fact that it is now
being chosen as a name for an element
that was synthesized in Russia is a
wonderful indication of peace Livermore
is I believe the name of the place not
far from San Francisco where the lab was
so it was the lawrence lab that's in the
city of Livermore so it was the Lawrence
Livermore Lab I think the name is okay
but livermorium sounds to me I don't
know why perhaps by sense of word
association slightly beside in the sense
of mournful because it sounds rather
like the English word in memoriam which
means in memory of somebody who's died
but I'm from the point of view of
pronunciation and so on living ballroom
is fine these elements are just a few
atoms that
been made not all at once one atom at a
time over a period of months so nobody
knows anything about the properties of
these elements but if you look at the
periodic table here you can see the
element 114 here is in the same group
group 14 as carbon silicon and so on and
LED so you would expect if you could get
enough atoms all at once that 114 would
be very heavy dense metal rather like
lead element 116 is in the same group as
polonium I don't really know what the
properties of polonium are tenoram is a
very smelly element it's chemical smell
dreadful so it's possible that if you
could make compounds of elements 116
they would be the smelliest compounds in
the periodic table hydrogen livermorium
hydrogen Livermore I'd would be really
something that would smell but I must
say that when we started periodic videos
three and a half years ago I never
dreamt that there'd be all these new
elements that were being named and to
being named on one day is really quite
exciting it seems to be even-numbered
elements that keep getting named well
for reasons that I don't entirely
understand even-numbered elements are
more stable than those that are odd
numbers it's something to do with the
number of protons being more stable when
you have an even number of protons and
as they get heavier and heavier you're
always on the tip of them decomposing so
if you have an even number even a tiny
difference in stability is gonna make a
difference
I suspect that certainly up to 118 the
odd numbers will also be confirmed but
with the new row there's a thoughts that
a hundred and twenty may be much more
stable in 919